so i guess you're not gonna hurt me huh  starting to understand the situation  what do you want from me  unless you think your wife  is gonna be better off with a husband  who has a bloody stump for a head i want  you to sit down on that curb put your  hands in your head and do nothing until  i speak with these officers nothing no  no curb i'm not putting my hands on my  head but nobody  then stand right where you are and keep  your hands in plain sight can you do  that huh  yeah i can do that  good  told this man to stay where he is and  keep his hands in plain sight i don't  think i i  like massage anymore mr kazoo premium  fantasy  my stockings  live there  leave my stockings  yes please  leave there  what  lift them  hey leave my stocking hey lift them blip  them what lift them like this  lift them rip them lip yeah you want me  to rip your stockings rip my study